it was a remarkable moment
inconceivable just a few years ago
[Music]
a papal pilgrimage into the heart of a
city destroyed
[Music]
pope francis had been insistent he would
get here
and so he did driven he says by a
determination to inspire hope
and here more than anywhere they need
some of that
all around him what's left of mosul a
city and its soul
destroyed by the islamic state and the
battle to reclaim it
the church is one of many in mosul in
pieces
the cross is made from the burnt chairs
recovered from inside
this was a moment of prayer for the
nearly 10 000 civilians
who died here and so many more who were
wounded
in a visit full of historic firsts this
is surely the most
symbolic moment the pope in the rubble
of a city which came to define
extremist intolerance and here with his
message of peace
he was shown the narrow alleys where
street to street fighting just four
years ago
was the fiercest of any since world war
ii
he's planting the seed of peace in mosul
she says
and for the first time in our country's
history we hear iraq's name associated
with beautiful things
in the christian town of karakosh in
streets where public beheadings took
place
he was with the people who survived the
hell of isis
in these days of a global health crisis
and great insecurity
at times like these remember that jesus
is by your side
do not stop dreaming do not give up do
not lose hope
[Music]
for all the controversy of this trip the
concerns of coronavirus
for the people here it was so necessary
near the mosul mosque where the isis
leader declared his caliphate seven
years ago
under a statue to honor those rebuilding
the city
we met ali barudi it was not even
possible to walk
through these streets it was full of
booby traps and
ices explosives and dead bodies in the
alleys and the houses
and unfortunately they are still digging
and taking more and more dead bodies
from the riverside
district of maidan still four years on
yes
[Music]
and then the culmination of this visit a
stadium in the iraqi kurdish capital
erbil
for sunday mass here security allowed
for an open sided pokemobile
it had the feel of a more normal papal
appearance yet
it's been anything but his motives for
coming here
are to inspire hope in a region that
needs it well
then yes he has certainly done that
all of this the moment in mosul and the
meeting yesterday with the grand
ayatollah
provided a particular reassurance for
people here
the dialogue and understanding between
religions is the message from the top
[Applause]
that means something in a region where
tolerance of the other
has run so thin mark stone sky news
in iraq